companies in the S P 500 are on Pace to
buy back more than one trillion dollars
worth of their own stock this year a
record high Warren Buffett recently
defended stock BuyBacks or at least
insisted that they're not always bad but
these companies are buying record
amounts to their stock at a time when
investors are largely selling their
shares I'm going to explain why
companies are buying back their stock
right now what stock BuyBacks are and
how they benefit corporations and why
this could be a risky gamble for some of
the Market's big names
let's get into it Goldman Sachs recently
authorized 30 billion dollars of plant
stock BuyBacks and Facebook parent meta
announced plans to buy 40 billion
dollars of their own stock this might
sound like an odd use of capital given
that these Company stock prices have
sunk and they've recently announced
thousands of layoffs data show that both
institutional investors and Retail
investors have been selling stock in
recent weeks but companies like to buy
back stock during market sell-offs for a
number of reasons first seeing the
company buy signals to investors that
management still sees the stock is
attractive it shows they're putting some
skin in the game second with growing
uncertainty in the market investors are
saying BuyBacks are what they want Bank
of America's latest Global fund manager
survey shows the percentage of investors
who want companies to return cash to
shareholders is it the highest since
2017. third the latest earnings results
show S P 500 companies are generating
lower net profits and seeing their
pricing power decline by purchasing
their own stock companies can improve
their earnings per share numbers making
the the stock more attractive to
investors when you calculate earnings
per share lower earnings don't look so
bad if there are fewer shares it's also
important to note that top Executives
pay packages are often tied to the
company's stock price so a higher stock
price often means more money for CEOs
and others who decide how to deploy a
company's Capital but what are stock
BuyBacks and why do companies do them in
the first place when companies go public
they sell shares to anyone who wants
them when companies buy back their stock
they literally buy available shares from
market makers or individual shareholders
BuyBacks have historically increased the
Stock's price because as our economics
textbook teaches us when Supply
decreases and demand stays the same
prices typically rocks but BuyBacks are
not without their risks big companies
like meta and Goldman have lots of cash
on their balance sheets but others could
run in some serious trouble with
interest rates Rising it will be much
more expensive for companies to buy our
money some firms could find themselves
running out of cash while still needing
to pay employees vendors and suppliers
that could create a cash crunch where
companies have to sell off assets or
declare bankruptcy so when companies
announce BuyBacks some investors buy
because it usually means the price will
be rising but some sell because it can
also mean that the company is getting
desperate and has more concern with its
stock price than with investing in the
company itself
these CEOs may be following the advice
of the late great nipsy hustle who said
in 2018 I laid down the game for you
taught you how to charge more than what
they paid for own the whole thing for
you reinvest double up then explain for
you
that's all for now see you next time